i want to start with how fantastic i
thought you guys were in this film uh i
watched this last night and i thought it
captured a again you guys are fantastic
but i thought it captured and
articulated what so many of us are
feeling you know dennis kelly's script
is just uh awesome you know that's
awesome
nice one that's it see you later thanks
man and i'm out
but i like starting off with like a a
you know an oddball question so um what
tv series would each of you like to
guest star on
oh that's good battlestar galactica but
it's no longer on
it's coming back actually is it yeah
yeah uh sam esmail the guy who did mr
robot he's developing it right now okay
well that's me just throwing my hat in
the ring there isn't it oh [ __ ]
um
selling sunset
[Laughter]
wait is that a cat or a dog
oh that is a dog i i got a cat though
very recently as well but that whoa whoa
so you're now a dog and a cat person
yeah i'm a dog and i'm a dog and a cat
person james i thought i just i thought
i thought you couldn't get any more
interesting
um
as i said before jumping into the movie
um i loved the script for each of you
what was it that you most responded to
uh with the dialogue and what uh you
were trying to say with the film just
from a enjoyment point of view um the
the the
the the sort of uh quick fire um
bantering with each other i i just knew
it would be really fun to do like i
thought it would be hard because i i you
know the way dennis writes they they
you know um a lot of the sentences are
sort of unfinished and
you know um
you he he sort of
you're sort of responding to something
that's been said earlier it sort of
jumps all around the place and
and um but i thought that i really
thought that would be fun and a joy to
do like i i sort of really enjoy that in
in in in sort of old films you know like
his girl friday kind of thing
i i've always watched it and loved it
and and and i found it really um really
fun but um
you know i i also felt it it could be a
real um emotional roller coaster to
perform to do something that's like pure
out night uh comedy like really we're
making an audience laugh and we really
want to make them laugh
and and then and then telling stories
that are supposed to be entirely
heartbreaking like there's no levity
there at all and to be able to pull to
be able to do both of those things and
make it tonally
you know uh cohesive i i think is a real
um
um challenge and so i was looking
forward to doing that
look there was many many things i think
getting to work with her was
a massive thing um
within about two or three pages of
reading the script i knew i wanted to do
it but you gotta have the right person
to do it with them getting to do it with
sharon was was huge um and then she
delivers as well and she thumbs up and
she's hilarious and lovely and an
amazing professional and amazing actor
so that was good but also i think
specifically one of the things that
stuck with me was uh when i first read
it was the fact that he's got things
that he wants to say dennis is a good
things he wants to say politic not
political but kind of politically but um
just basically holding a torch up to
what happened and the fact of what
happened and the mismanagement of what
happened he's got things he wants to say
about how we all evolved or how some
people evolved during the pandemic
during the lockdowns but he does them in
such a good way there is one point in
the script what he just flat out says oh
and it's so powerful but for the rest of
the time he usually disguises it in a
really cool story that you're going why
am i listening to this funny interesting
sad and or exciting story and then right
at the end you realize that the whole
thing
was about this point that he's trying to
make and
it was just so elegantly done and
entertainingly done that i thought you
know this could be it's just two people
talking for 90 minutes and yet it's one
of the most compelling things i think
i'd read in years
the interesting thing is both of you
guys are trained to never look at the
camera and you have to look at the
camera in this film
at what point were you actually
comfortable looking at the camera or was
it during rehearsal you got used to it
i like the idea that i've been trained
not to look at the camera
it makes me feel like every time i don't
look at the camera i get a treat and
then if i do look at the camera i get
told off
uh which i like that idea i'm i have
been well trained and i look i i just
feel like it's the exact same as
standing on stage and talking to the
audience that's exactly how i felt i've
done very very little theater like one
play
uh and and i so i wasn't used to it and
stephen
before the cameras came in we we had
like you know a couple of weeks of
rehearsal where the st stephen dolgy was
just the camera and he wouldn't let me
uh break eye contact with him and and
that was the
that was the thing that i had to learn
you know um was to to not look away and
to just like
uh because it unnerves you you know it
it doesn't hurt you but when when you do
it it's really it's amazing and i'd
never sort of done anything
like that before so now i'm like
now i'm like i carry that around as my
new knowledge that i have when i really
do you think this don't you think this
thing spoiled us we said it
like i i read so much now and i'm like
ah
it's not as good as that
totally
um the you have some takes that are 13
minutes how many times did you get to
the 10 or 11 minute mark and then
someone f's up and you're like get out
of here
all the time that first scene oh when we
were getting out of here
we never got angry at each other
no no no no um but the first scene
particularly oh my god we did that
20 times all the way through it
yeah and i think we got like two good
takes or three good takes
it was so upsetting like there were so
many that were just like singing
and then you get like two cents
and you you know
you knock a bottle over or whatever but
like um
but uh
yeah it's sort of um it's just just par
for the course isn't it it's just it's
what happens and the weird thing that
you have to
um do or not think about is that very
thing i mean because otherwise you just
like
you know
sort of i don't know what i'm doing but
i think i said a tip-toeing tip
you just you know it would affect you
every time you do it like is am i going
to get to the end and then you start
thinking about the end before you've got
there and that's the pro that's like the
you know like on your race horse falling
at the last hurdle kind of thing like um
but you know it was also what um
in a way it was sort of what got it to
the place it needed to get to you know
we were so sort of relaxed and okay with
it at the end that um
i hope it came it you know it appeared
very natural and and organic
uh i have to go but i'm just gonna say
very fast my number one movie of next
year right now is the unbearable uh
weight of massive talent so
seriously congrats on this movie have a
fantastic day
cheers man see you bye